okay so this brings us to the last stop
and so this is also a very different
talk from what you have been hearing it
would be more about statistical modeling
for some recommender problem so it's a
two-part talk so first I'm going to
introduce you to what is what i call the
classical item recommendation problem
and again this problem have been worked
upon by many people and there is a rich
literature but i want to just give a
brief introduction just to make sure
everybody's on the same page and then
i'm going to i'm going to mention some
challenges that happen for these kind of
problems when you are trying to do
recommendation on a social network you
know like Twitter or LinkedIn or
Facebook I'm going to talk about
LinkedIn because I'd have access to that
data not the other two and then finally
now I'm going to do a deep dive on one
of the problems which is about
estimating reputations of users who
produce content on the social network
right and again this is just an example
the concepts hopefully would apply to
other problems as well of similar kind
so so here is the classical item
recommendation problems the goal here is
to serve the best items to users in an
automated fashion to optimize some
long-term objectives which could be user
engagement revenue in advertising and so
on so forth so here is an example if you
go to LinkedIn there is a module which
is called linkedin today and what this
module does it publishes news articles
it also publishes so it publishes news
articles of various kinds some of these
news articles are things that are shared
by users on external publisher sites
through the LinkedIn button so for
instance if you go to TechCrunch and you
like an article you can share it on
linkedin and you're going to pick it up
and if these are really good and
resonate very well with most of the
professionals on our network we are
going to show it here we also have what
are called influencers so these are
reputed people like Bill Gates and the
President and other people who actually
could write long form content on the
LinkedIn plant platform and we know if
an article is shared by someone whom you
are following we will also show it on
this model you
so these are the different kinds of
content we publisher and the goal at the
end of the day is to kind of recommend
articles that are going to maximize some
user engagement measured by some metric
like click-through rates right so the
classical problem and again as I said
this has been worked upon by many people
so you have a user I you know everything
about the user not everything whatever
they tell us about the user you know you
know which industry they are from you
know what their educational background
is what what what kind of skills they
possess where they have worked where
they are working now where they've
worked in the past and so on so forth
right and then you have a bunch of
articles or items in general and you
know there is some recommended algorithm
that chooses the best item to show and
then the user kind of gives you some
feedback which could be either a click
or a no click and so the question is
given this whole scenario how do you
select which items to show to the user
right is it all about getting an
estimated CTR and then just choosing the
max Arg max or is there more to it right
so ideally yes you would want to do that
if you knew the CTR without any error
you are going to choose the click you
are going to choose the article that has
the maximum CTR and serve it to the user
but unfortunately you never know the CTR
without error there is always a
statistical variance associated with
your estimated how do you mitigate that
variance is the key question here right
so that's the reason why you have to do
what is called an explorer exploits
strategy right so if you have enough
data on an article to estimate the CTR
without any error then you just serve
that you exploit whatever you have
learned but there may be many articles
in the pool which have not been shown a
large number of times and they are not
very certain about its estimate so you
may want to explore those articles even
though the empirical CTR looks low you
may still want to explore those articles
unless you are absolutely sure there's a
good or bad or articulate but this is
the classical Explorer exploit trade-off
which always someone always faces in
these kinds of problems just to kind of
give you a better idea of how these how
this trade-off works you know imagine a
simplified scenario where you have just
two articles in the
and the CTR of the first one is to 100
so it was shown 100 times when you got
two clicks and the other one was shown a
lot more 10,000 times and you got a CT
you got to 50 clicks so the greedy
solution is going to tell you to show
article 2 to the entire population but
that may not be a very good strategy
because there is more statistical
variation in terms for the CTR of
article 1 compared to article to write
so there is a finite probability that
item one might be better than art item 2
so you don't want to starve this item of
furthering further displays you you want
to keep showing this at least a few
times I'll tell you are absolutely sure
whether this is a better article than
two or worse article that tonight and so
how to do this exploration how much
display should you allocate to this
article versus this article is the
classical explore explore dilemma and
again you can work out the solution to
these things by using classical
multi-armed bandit strategies right so
so here is an example of some data which
was collected from the module I showed
you right so these are the click-through
rate of different articles that was
shown on linkedin today and as you can
see there is a lot of variation in the
CTR so it is not the case that a few
articles always dominate the rest and so
that's why it's not an easy problem you
know if you just do naive ranking it's
not going to work you have to do things
some simple explore exploit algorithm to
ensure that you pick up the best article
and you're maximizing the total number
of clicks you're getting on that morning
right again here is some here is a very
simple explore exploit skiing which you
can do right you take a small fraction
of traffic to that small fraction of
traffic use randomly show articles that
kind of gives you data on every single
thing that is introduced into the pool
and then you use that data to learn
about the popularity of those articles
and choose the one that is best for the
remaining ninety five percent right so
very simple explore exploit stream right
and again the solution which I was
talking about the third
did not do anything about
personalization so if you want to do
personalization there is no closed-form
orwell's well-known optimal solution to
this problem often what what is done is
heuristics right so one heuristic could
be the same as I described earlier you
always take a small fraction of traffic
where we randomly allocate data and then
you learn from those the other heuristic
which is often used is if you have a
very high dimensional problem when
you're doing personalization right
you're trying to figure out the best
article for every single user based on
all the features you have about them you
reduce the dimension of the problem
right and the way you reduce the
dimension of the problem is by using
some supervised machine learning
algorithm and then to explore exploit in
the lower dimensional subspace and so
again these heuristics work well in
practice there are some results known
about when these things could be optimal
but not very comprehensive okay so that
was the classical problem now let me
come to the what is called the feed
recommendation problem right so if you
go to LinkedIn or Twitter or Facebook
let's focus on linkedin here you know
linkedin publishes a feed where we can
show many different kinds of content to
a user right so some example of content
network updates so these are all updates
about your network right so if someone
in your network change is a job that is
something which I can publish on the
stream right and if it is a close
connection you might actually want to
know where they started working and so
on so forth if someone completed a job
anniversary that's also something i can
show if someone got connected to someone
else if someone endorses someone for
some skills if someone uploaded a new
photo so these are all different updates
which i can show on the stream and these
are all related to your connections in
the network and then you know if you are
following some influencers and if they
publish some article i can show that if
your friend shares an article that is
also something i can show on the stream
if you are following some what we call
content channels say about leadership or
java and if something comes up we can
show that if you are following a company
Google Twitter and if they publish
something
can show you that so if there is a new
job that has been posted by someone and
we believe that job is relevant to you
we can also show those things and
finally we also also show what are
called sponsored content so these are
more ads right so if a company wants to
broadcast a message and if two people
who are not following them they have to
publish it as an ad and that also can go
into the network update stream right so
the main difference here from the
classical item recommendation problem is
you don't have a single kind of item
that you are recommending to users it's
not like out of all the movies in the
world which one should I show you out of
all the news articles in the world which
one should I show you you know it's a
heterogeneous content pool having very
different characteristics some of them
are more influenced by your social
connections some of them may not be
involved with the social connection and
the challenge here is how do you solve
this recommendation problem when you
have such heterogeneous pool
incorporating not just the identity
behavioral data that you have about the
user but also these social affinities
that viewers have with some of these
content producing entities right so
that's really the main challenge right
and so the approach which we take to
this problem at LinkedIn is we take a
tiered approach to ranking again this is
primarily based on more for scalability
than anything else right so you know on
an tier 1 there are different kinds of
rancors so you might have a rancor that
produces the top news ranking you might
have an rancor that produces the top
network updates you might have a rancor
that produces the top ads and jobs and
so on so forth so these rankers when
they are called gives give out the top K
recommendations and then there is a
blending layer which kind of blends all
these different content type and
assembles the stream to be the most
engagement to the user so tomorrow
someone else wants to come up with a new
content type which they want to inject
into the stream all they have to do is
add another
over here and then the blender is going
to pick it up and if it is indeed
engaging relative to all the other
content that could be published to the
user it's going to get promoted in the
feed right so that's the approach you
take so some of the challenges I'm not
going to talk about the solution to this
problem today I am just kind of
outlining the challenges personalization
so the usual personalization when you
don't have a social network we all know
how that works like you kind of collect
all the information about the user and
then use it in your machine learning
model but when you are dealing with
social network if viewers affinity to
what we call the actor right actor is
someone who can produce content like if
you are changing a job you are actually
producing a content right what is what
is so the estimating these affinities
and also for different kinds of updates
is a very important problem so I might
have a very strong affinity to my friend
when it comes to them changing their job
but I might not like the articles that
they produce right so the affinities can
be different for different kinds of
updates and we have to estimate these
things in a statistically reliable
fashion to be using it then there are
effects like frequency discounting right
so if you see the same update multiple
times you kind of get bored and you
don't want to see it again so we have to
make sure that is there the content
should be fresh this also depends on the
kind of quantitative if your friend
changes a job and if you have not seen
it even if you know it after seven days
that's fine but if there is a news
article and if you know about it after
seven days that's not find right so the
degree of freshness which you need to
have four different kinds of content
right and then diversification when you
are assembling the stream using
different kinds of content you don't
want to show all jobs on the first three
slot even though there may be awesome
jobs and you are actually interested in
seeing a job it is better to mix up
things right so if you are showing a job
on slot one maybe you want to show
something else onslaught two right there
are multiple it's a there are multiple
objectives that one has to adhere to and
you're assembling this stream so if you
are showing an ad you want to maximize
revenue but at the same time you don't
want to show ads that are jarring to the
user you know
you want to make sure that the
engagement is also preserved a be
testing right so whenever you are
rolling out a new methodology to the
stream you want to run a bucket where
you allocate the new algorithm or you
serve using the new algorithm to a
random population and then there is
another random population that is the
control group however when you have a
social network there could be spillover
effects right so if I get a new
algorithm and I start sharing a lot of
articles because it is popping up in my
stream those articles would then become
candidates that could be shown to my
friends in who are in the control group
and it's not very clear whether the
impact of the new algorithm is better
than the control when there are such
spillover effects right so one needs new
methodology to do a/b testing when there
is such interference going on between
populations right engagement metrics
right so people user to engage with the
stream in different way right they might
click on something they might
congratulate a friend when they change a
job they might share something how do
you take these different actions that
users have on the stream and combine
them and come up with a function which
is representative in some sense of their
long-term engagement on the side right
so that's another challenging problem
right and finally I mean this is
something is I'm going to talk about a
little bit in whatever time I have left
now there are many users on the stream
who are producing content ID so when you
are sharing something you're actually
producing content that can be broadcast
to your network can I use those kind of
data to estimate your reputation for
instance in a given topic right so if
you produce articles say in Java or
algorithms that are liked by the
population at large that means your
reputation for that particular topic
should be high and once you can compute
such reputations course that could be
used in various places on the site to
improve results right so I'm going to
talk about this a little bit more and
finally summarization right so as I as I
mentioned we are free to inject new
kinds of content into the street right I
might come up with a content something
like top articles read by CX source in
the last week and pre create create
stream like that will create a content
summary like that and start injecting
into the stream and it might actually
resonate very well with the user so this
is a new kind of problem right when we
are talking about algorithms or machine
learning we always assume there is a
given problem there is an objective
function got to maximize that here this
is a more open-ended somewhat related to
clustering problem where you can
actually take whatever content we have
on our ecosystem and create attractive
somebody is out of those and then show
it to the user and see whether it works
or not so that's another open problem at
field that has not been tackled in the
past right okay so these are some plots
so I was talking about the impression
discounting so this is what happens so
if a user sees the same update multiple
time the CTR keep decaying not very
surprising I mean this is an effect
which I be the most of us have seen when
we working with problems like that how
does the response rate change so this is
how the response rate changes so this is
showing the effect of diversity right so
if the same update type have been seen
by the users user in positions above in
positions above what what we are
focusing on now then again the CTR DK
right so if you see three jobs in the
first two position then your CTR on the
third position is going to go down
compared to if you don't see any job
right so this kind of shows the
diversification of rectum diversifying
recommendations among different types is
also very important and again finally
freshness so freshness again depends
right so if you are looking at content
like anniversary as freshness matters
but you know if you're looking if
someone commented on something and you
show it even after seven days to your
friend it still kind of works pretty
well so freshness depends on what kind
of content you are looking at on Twitter
maybe when you're sharing links
freshness matters more but on linkedin
there are some that are time sensitive
others are not right and we have to
figure out which one of these are time
sensitive which one these are not okay
pardon
the age in ours yes okay so five minutes
okay so so let me just go through a
particular problem and again this is
something i call estimating reputation
of a user in a given topic so the so
reputation in this case is defined as
the likelihood of a positive response by
an anonymous user to an article scheid
by a user right so your reputation in
algorithm is the propensity of an
anonymous user whom you don't know to
click on the article that are shared by
you right so that that's the reputation
of this is very different from what is
called influence that have been studied
in graph theory quite a bit right if you
share an article how quickly does it
diffuses or what is the reach of your
share in the network is what is called
influence in in general but reputation
is different right this is how is a how
will I user who is not connected to you
would respond to a typical article that
is produced by you right and so it's not
very easy to estimate this reputation
from the network data we have because
the network data is biased right and
again here is an example of why it is
biased right so you know there is
selection bias so whatever you share is
only shown to the people who are
connected to you and again there is also
response bias right so if you are a grad
student and if your adviser is sharing
something then you are more likely to
respond to it you just out of politeness
I guess so so that also creates bias in
terms of reputation so maybe your
adviser is not very reputed in
particular topic but may start looking
reputed because he has a lot of students
which is not the right reputation score
okay so here is one approach we took so
so the idea here is how do you Debus the
data and so so the way we do it is as
follows so the so the goal here is can
we collect some ground truth unbiased
data on reputation again this ground
truth data cannot be available in large
quantities it would be available in some
small quantities in some aggregated form
and then combine that with all
network data and then kind of D bias
right so that is the really is the main
idea here and so here is an example so
on linkedin today when we are showing an
article you as a user don't know who are
the people who actually shared these
article there might be five people who
appreciate this article from all over
the web but you don't know who they
share did you click on the article if
you like it or you don't like it right
whereas in on the stream you know who is
sharing the article and you're
responding based on both the quality of
the article and perhaps who the sharer
is right so this is in some sense and
unbiased data and this is biased can we
combine both and come up with a unbiased
reputation score right so so you can do
something like this through some
statistical model right so again this is
I'm not going to go through all the
details you can read it in the paper but
the main idea here is you are getting
some response or J is the article is the
user so you are getting some response to
articles on the on the unbiased on the
LinkedIn today for LinkedIn today which
is more unbiased and again this response
is a function of the popularity of that
article in that particular topic right
and so now there is a latent model that
is assuming that the popularity of an
article in a particular topic depends on
the reputation of the people who are
sharing those articles but the five
people who shared the article then the
popularity of that article on linkedin
today is an average of the reputation of
people who shared this article right so
this is something that is late and you
don't know you know the goal here is to
estimate this quantity which is the
unbiased sharer reputation and then on
the feed you can also say well the
probability of responding to article I
by user J when it is shared by user s is
also a function of the reputation of the
user but again this is biased right
because there's all kinds of response
bias these and you know selection bias
easy over here right so now the question
is how do you connect this with this
this is really the crux of the problem
can I get an estimate of this by using
this data which is kind of meager and
using information here right can I kind
of transfer information here and here to
kind of get a nest
do this right and you can do that I mean
this is one way of doing it so you kind
of say okay well the unbiased reputation
score is connected to the biased
reputation score which can be estimated
very reliably because I have a lot of
data on the stream through some
regression function we can regress this
with this and then this kind of leads to
D biasing the data so I'm not going to
go through those other details I mean
there are some other details here but
that's the main idea connecting
connecting the sharer reputation which
you are obtaining from the unbiased data
with very sparse data with something
which is bias and D biasing the whole
process through some linear function yes
not saying that there's some pies see
with a particular share and a particular
talking yes because also people who just
or share in description d bias I just
share the time that would be a different
kind of bias yeah so in this function i
ignored this person one of the feature
could be just have one right so there
will be some main effect and then there
will be some other effects based on the
user's yes yes it is implicit in this I
didn't go through the deal but it is
intrinsic versus but that's a good
question yes right and so so we okay so
this is all great now how do you know it
is actually working right again these
things are very hard to evaluate in
practice but we did some rough
evaluation so the way we did the
evaluation was and I'm running out of
time but let me just explain the
evaluation so we took some as usual some
training data and some test data right
and okay so this is what we do so we
took data in some time period and create
these unbiased reputation score using
the model and then what we do is we take
out some users in the training data and
see what the average click-through rate
was on linkedin today for article that
was shared by them in in June right so
it may is the training data June is what
was the average click-through rate for
articles that you shared in June right
so this is your test data now if a
method if the reputation score produced
by method a is highly correlated with
the average click-through rate of
article that are shared by you on
LinkedIn today in June then that means
that the better method compared to
something else where the correlation is
we right so that is the evaluation
method we used and you can see so we
compared it with different page rank
algorithm page rank algorithms are
supposed to estimate influence rather
than reputation right so as expected you
know the page rank algorithms do not
have enough correlation with this at all
but if you kind of do the D biasing the
way I described you start getting good
results in terms of correlation right so
again this is just an example of how you
can utilize information in the social
networks and combine it with some other
ground truth to kind of come up with
very nice estimates of things which you
would which you would like to have but
you cannot get just by using the social
data right because I'm out of time but
you know just a few takeaways so
recommendation problem as I said in a
social network are challenging and I
kind of outlined all the challenges
before in by using the example of feed
recommendation and again I discussed the
estimation of an unbiased sharer
reputation today but several other
problems I believe can benefit from this
approach because you know for instance
you know if you are looking at
endorsements on linkedin you know
endorsements are also biased right i
mean you know people who are connected
to you might endorse you more than
people who are not connected so if you
have very high degree you generally get
more endorsement that doesn't mean you
are really an expert in that particular
area but can you crawl the web and get
the h-index of authors some small set of
authors and kind of have that as a
ground truth and then combine that with
the social data that's your LinkedIn and
come up with a better unbiased estimator
of reputation for instance right I mean
that could be one example of how you can
use this techniques now of course the
modeling would change quite dramatically
it would not be the same whatever the
ideas could still go when you're solving
problems like that so with that I'm
sorry I went a little late thank you
you